schönen guten abend herr presse guten
abend
wir haben da noch mal gesehen welche
zusagen deutschland gemacht hat und was
bislang geliefert wurde wie bewerten sie
denn den aktuellen status quo
na ja mit sehr gemischten gefühlen also
erst einmal dass sich gewisse
lieferungen verzögern oder dass gewisse
lieferungen strecken über die zeit das
war bekannt weil eben komplexere
waffensysteme panzerhaubitze 2000 zb
oder auch der gepard natürlich einen
ausbildungs oder logistik vorlauf
brauchen das heißt sie müssen techniker
in der ukraine ausbilden wie sie das
ding warten können sie müssen diese
soldaten die bedien mannschaften
ausbilden und das dauert alles zeit
das problem bei deutschland ist gering
die ringe tauschen zum beispiel der mit
tschechien derart sinn gemacht weil
tschechien sozusagen upfront wie man das
in englisch sagt geliefert hat also
sofort die 72 ausgeschieden hat damit
hat man zeit geworden in der 72 wird
jetzt irgendwann im herbst durch
deutsche leopard assets die nicht so
schnell einsatzbereit gemacht werden
konnten als die tschechen die 70 liefern
der ringtausch die mader nach
griechenland zu schicken ist eine
völlige eine verschwendung dieses gerät
weil die griechischen bmp 1 in der
qualität deutlich schlechter sind und
auch jetzt erst wieder mal flott gemacht
werden müssen und erst viel später in
die ukraine gehen können als wenn man
die marder direkt geliefert hätte und da
kommen wir schon bei den kernpunkt es
gibt so gewisse selbst restriktionen in
deutschland kampfpanzer schützenpanzer
die man in ukraine kaum versteht dann
gewisses altes gebrauchtes gerät das in
deutschen rüstungsschmieden herumsteht
werden das nicht vom bundeswehr gerät
sondern vom gerät das durch andere
länder zurückgegeben wurde das ist im
grunde frei das wird wahrscheinlich
irgendwann auf dem schrottplatz landen
oder ist in der ukraine und da ist es
halt in ukraine du schon besser
aufgehoben ja wenn sie das aktuelle
kriegsgeschehen in der ukraine
analysieren würden sie dann sagen dass
russland nach anfänglichen
schwierigkeiten die allenthalben zu
beobachten waren jetzt seine taktik
angepasst und verbessert hat denn
inzwischen hat man ja doch den eindruck
dass zumindest an ausgesuchten stellen
gerade an der ostfront russland die
oberhand
russland hat sein verhalten taktisch
angepasst das macht keine
tiefen manöver mehr als man trinkt nicht
dutzende wenn nicht hunderte kilometer
tiefen ukrainisches territorium ein und
wundert sich dann dass man die soldaten
nicht versorgen kann sondern man geht
relativ langsam durchschnitts angriffs
geschwindigkeit ist 1,5 kilometer pro
tag vor man zerschießt systematisch mit
artillerie die ukrainischen stellungen
und rückt dann mit vielen panzern auf
diese vor so minimiert man die eigenen
verluste die hohen eigenen verluste
haben wir für die sinkende moral in der
russischen armee vor allen dingen
gesorgt das hat man jetzt auch behoben
und so rückt man vor und so minimiert
man die eigenen verluste man maximiert
die der ukraine man nutzt die schwäche
der ukraine im bereich feuerkraft aus
und maximiert die eigene überlegenheit
und nutzt das taktisch cleverer das geht
natürlich langsam und es ist sozusagen
noch nicht aller tage abend hierbei auf
natürlich die ukraine sich jetzt neu
einstellt wie russland vorgeht und auch
den russen hatte verluste zugefügt aber
in einem abnutzungskrieg in einem
langfristigen abnutzungskrieg sind das
natürlich für die ukraine deutlich
schlechtere karten als noch im frühling
weil man eben nicht weiß wie viel
material aus dem westen nach kommt weil
die eigene rüstungsindustrie zu einem
sehr großen teil zerstört wurde durch
luftangriffe und man jetzt nicht weiß
wie man diesen abnutzungskrieg
langfristig durchhalten will
danke bis hierhin ufer lachmann sagt uns
oder schreibt uns über facebook was
bezweckt man mit der unterstützung dass
der krieg nicht so schnell auf wird
profit für die rüstungsindustrie schick
lieber weiße flaggen in die ukraine
damit das sterben aufhört diesen
standpunkt vertreten einige aber in der
ukraine ist das soweit ich weiss nicht
die mehrheitsmeinung ein vorwurf der aus
kiew immer wieder erhoben wird zuletzt
auch wieder von präsident zwanziger
selbst ist dass deutschland zu langsam
und auch zu zögerlich agieren würden sie
dem zustimmen und wenn ja warum ist das
so aus ihrer sicht
also es gibt einen gewissen bereichen
gibt es sehr lange in politische
diskussionen
es gibt
oder man hat in der ukraine auf das
gefühl dass aus deutschland auch aus
anderen teilen westeuropas der ukraine
ein sieg eigentlich nicht zugetraut wird
und das was man liefert eigentlich nur
sozusagen dem druck geschuldet ist der
aufgebaut wird durch andere alliierte
und durch die eigene bevölkerung die
öffentliche meinung in deutschland ist
überwiegend auf der seite der ukraine
und wünscht sich eine entschiedene
haltung der bundesregierung und das
erweckt den eindruck der strategie
losigkeit dass man getrieben ist von
umfragedaten und dass man ein
waffensystem verspricht wenn die
umfragewerte im keller liegen aber dass
man keinen systematischen plan hat
niemand kräne unter die arme greift
einen abnutzungskrieg zu gewinnen welche
welche zeitlinien man planen muss welche
güter bereitzustellen sondern dass das
alles noch sehr adhoc ist und dass das
nicht wirklich durch die militärischen
notwendigkeiten bedingt ist sondern
durch innenpolitische stimmung
sie haben gerade die öffentliche meinung
angesprochen das ist ganz interessant in
dem zusammenhang könnte die folgende
studie nämlich auf von relevanz sein die
ihr haus der european council on foreign
relations gemacht hat und einige
ergebnisse dieser studie die können uns
jetzt gerade noch mal gemeinsam
anschauen
russland trägt die hauptschuld an
kriegen der ukraine das sagen in
finnland 90 prozent der befragten
großbritannien und polen schließen sich
dem mit jeweils 83 prozent an in
deutschland finden nur 66 prozent dass
russland für den krieg verantwortlich
ist 20 prozent weisen der ukraine der eu
oder den usa die schuld zu in italien
sind lediglich 56 prozent der meinung
dass russland die haupt schuld am krieg
trägt sollte wegen russlands
angriffskriegs mehr in die eigene
verteidigung investiert werden ja sagen
52 prozent der befragten in polen und
nehmen dafür auch in kauf dass bereiche
wie gesundheit und bildung
möglicherweise weniger geld bekommen
schweden folgt dem mit 50 und
deutschland mit 41 prozent italien auch
hier wieder schlusslicht mit nur 14
prozent zustimmung die frage ob alle
wirtschaftlichen beziehungen zu russland
gekappt werden sollten beantworten in
deutschland 7 und 5 80 prozent mit ja
45 prozent sagen auch die kulturellen
beziehungen sollten abgebrochen werden
bei den diplomatischen beziehungen sind
es 39 prozent der bevölkerung
ja da waren doch der kessel einige
interessante zahlen dabei gehen wir es
gerade noch mal durch hat es sie
überrascht dass in deutschland nur 66
prozent der menschen russland für den
krieg hauptverantwortlich machen in
anderen ländern war es noch weniger aber
man könnte ja denken die zahlen werden
vielleicht höher aber wenn ich meinen
teil der öffentlichen debatte anschaue
ist das eigentlich nicht überraschend
also es gibt ja in allen shows oder in
allen größeren debatten immer jemand der
sagt ja eigentlich ist die nato
osterweiterung schuld eigentlich sind
die ukrainer selber schuld also es gibt
diese meinung ja auch im öffentlichen
raum und dass die einen widerhall in der
gesellschaft findet ist jetzt eigentlich
nicht nicht sonderlich verwunderlich war
wie hier durch deutschland eigentlich
positiv überrascht in vielen fällen vor
allen dingen was zb die die bereitschaft
dann auch wirtschaftliche last zu tragen
durch diesen krieg angeht wenn man sich
anschaut dass er teile der industrie im
märz noch getrommelt haben dass jede art
von jagow also den zusammenbruch des
sozialstaats bedeuten und alle möglichen
horrorszenarien an die wand geworfen
haben das hat doch weniger weil weniger
leute beeindruckt als gedacht und
vielleicht haben sie auch gesehen dass
mittlerweile der staat nicht
zusammenbricht also ich sehe dass die
öffentliche meinung hier nicht zu
kritisch ich finde die oeste die
deutsche öffentliche meinung ist in
vielen fällen
mehr in der lage als teile des
politischen berlins die sich mehr um die
eigenen befindlichkeiten kümmern ich
finde auch die solidarität für die
ukraine ist in der deutschen bevölkerung
ja durchaus ausgeprägt und
und auch wirklich stark rumpf ragt über
youtube wenn die bundeswehr nicht viel
hat versteht dass jeder warum lässt man
die industrieproduktion nicht hochfahren
die industrieproduktion fährt in einigen
teilen und einigen staaten auch möglich
hoch in deutschland ist ist da das
problem dass zu eben zu vielen klassen
von fahrzeugen es keine export
bescheinigungen gibt das heißt die
rüstungsindustrie die meisten geräte die
an die ukraine geliefert werden könnten
die stehende nicht bei der bundeswehr um
sondern die stehen im bereich der
rüstungsindustrie das und
zurückgenommene fahrzeuge aus anderen
streitkräften in europa und zum teil aus
der bundeswehr die schon ausgeschieden
sind und der wird gezankt ob man jetzt
exportieren darf oder soll man das nicht
tut oder ob man erst warten soll auf
andere nato-staaten dass die vorangehen
diese rüstungs klassen zu liefern und
damit verliert man zeit was die
produktion von munition angeht in
schweden in den usa in der slowakei in
polen wird die munitions produktion hoch
gekurbelt das problem ist natürlich das
geschieht auch nicht über nacht
industrie politik und die die
industrielle vorbereitung für so einen
krieg auf dieser größe wie wir sie in
der ukraine leben die braucht natürlich
ihre vorbereitung die brauchte ihre zeit
wir kämpfen hier und der ukraine kämpft
hier auf einer front die 1200 kilometer
lang ist es werden auf ukrainischer
seite um die 55 bis 6000 schuss
artilleriemunition pro tag verschossen
auf russischer seite sind das zuspitzen
tagen an angriffen 50.000 schuss
artilleriemunition pro tag pro tag und
es haben viele in europa einfach nicht
begriffen was ein krieg der zwei
grössten land armeen in europa
industriell und materiell bedeutet aber
muss man dann nicht vielleicht doch fast
michael i ag zustimmen der uns schreibt
die ukraine kann nichts mehr machen
außer so früh wie möglich mit russland
verhandlungen aufzunehmen
sonst verlieren sie noch mehr gebiete
würde das was sie gerade beschreiben
nicht sozusagen dieser meinung vorschub
leisten dass man am ende ja eigentlich
gar keine perspektive keine chance hat
die gh2 probleme das erste ist russland
will nicht verhandelt das zweite ist
wenn wenn die ukraine die russischen
bedingungen erfüllt dann geht auch auf
der ukrainischen seite das sterben
weiter weil es dann ein besatzungsregime
gibt das ein resultat der wir ja in
buschehr in anderen städten erlebt haben
die ukraine führt zurzeit einen krieg in
dem sie ihre eine eigene überlegenheit
an menschen nämlich dadurch dass sie
durch die generalmobilmachung durch die
hohe anzahl von freiwilligen hat mehr
fußsoldaten hat als die als die
russische seite
versucht so weit wie möglich zu ihrem
vorteil zu nutzen in ortschaften zu
kämpfen im bebauten gebiet zu kämpfen in
wäldern zu kämpfen zu sehen dass man die
ukraine ins dass man die russischen
streitkräfte ins in verträge lände
zwingt und dann einfach durch die
inkaufnahme eigene opfer an menschen
verluste an rüstungsmaterial auf der
russischen seite zu erzwingen das ist
brutal aber das ist natürlich eine
gesellschaft die mit dem rücken zur wand
und die als einzige alternative die
kulturelle und soziale auslöschung hat
eine verständliche taktik aber deshalb
spielt ja auch zuletzt so stark auf die
schweren waffen weil er natürlich dass
auch nicht sein schon leid ist
beziehungsweise auch nicht ewig
durchhalten kann jeden tag über 100
ukrainische familien das
kondolenzschreiben für söhne für brüder
und für für onkel zu überreichen aber
aus ukrainischer sicht es geht ums
überleben und sozusagen ein kapitulation
frieden steht nicht zur diskussion
weil ein kapitulation frieden noch
schlimmeres bringt als der krieg jetzt
schon ist wie sehen sie denn die
situation mittel bis langfristig es
heißt ja immer die ukraine dürfe den
krieg nicht verlieren beziehungsweise
manchmal auch andersrum russland dürfe
ihn nicht gewinnen aber wie würden sie
jetzt zum beispiel definieren was wann
der fall ist
das hängt zu einem erheblichen maße von
der bereitschaft des westens ab die
ukraine auch militärisch zu unterstützen
und es gibt
vor allen dingen auch in den usa auch
noch bestände an gebrauchten gerät aus
der zeit des kalten krieges die man
anzapfen kann das dauert zum teil im
bereich der vorbereitung eben logistik
und ausbildung durchaus noch eine zeit
aber das kann man machen
da da trifft jetzt washington was man
auch zu deutschland sagen muss die
bisherigen zusagen waren zu zögerlich
ich hoffe nur dass hier das sich in
washington hier die stimmung dann
entscheiden da und schneller auch
wandeln und wenden wie wird aber es gibt
das material um der ukraine zu
ermöglichen hier diesen krieg durchaus
zu gewinnen beziehungsweise
einem einem kapitulation frieden zu
entgehen die das material gibt es
politische wille muss im westen nur
wachsen ist mal 04 schreibt uns nochmal
anfangs war man ja überrascht wie stark
die ukraine schienen wie schwach
russland erleben wir hier gerade einen
game changer dreht sich die militärische
lage gerade
wir sehen dass sich die logistische lage
in einigen bereichen dreht ich würde
noch vorsichtig sein zu sagen die
ukraine ist jetzt sozusagen am
absteigenden ast die ukraine hat große
schwierigkeiten in einigen bereichen man
muss aber auch sagen dass zum beispiel
in class soll jetzt eine gegenoffensive
der ukraine noch läuft und gerade am
heutigen tag erfolge gebracht hat wenn
man hier zum beispiel eine bestellung
erreicht dann werden erhebliche
ukrainische kräfte wieder frei die man
wieder in den dom was bringen kann auch
gepanzerte kräfte mechanisierte kräfte
also es ist noch nicht aller tage abend
es ist nur enorm brenzlig und es ist den
ukrainer natürlich auch klar dass das
was sie erreichen können an frieden oder
an sicherheit dass sie das nur über
enorme menschenopfer erreichen werden
können und das ist für sie natürlich
keine sehr schöne perspektive
wie schätzen sie das ein ihr kollege
herfried münkler zum beispiel im fokus
war heute ein gespräch mit ihm oder bzw
einen aufsatz von ihm geht davon aus
dass russland den krieg langfristig
gewinnt einfach aufgrund der tatsache
dass die ukraine der wie er es nannte
asymmetrischen kriegsführung nichts
entgegenzusetzen hätte und auch der
drohung mit atomarem potenzial und auch
der westen irgendwie darauf noch keine
überzeugende strategische antwort
gefunden habe wie würden sie die
situation beurteilen
das sehe ich überhaupt nicht so also die
die drohung mit der großen atom mit dem
großen finale nuklearen krieg die ist
teil der russischen psychologischen
kampfführung schon seit geraumer zeit
aber erstens russland bei dem russland
gegen die nato einen atomkrieg anfangen
müsste er sich auch gedanken machen zu
welchen bedingungen es da raus kommt
außer jetzt der totalen eigenen
auslöschung und da hat russland in der
gegenwärtigen situation wo auch die
konventionellen streitkräfte in der
ukraine gebunden sind keine guten
chancen und nukleare kriegsführung und
konventioneller kriegsführung müssen
sich immer ergänzen sonst kommt man dann
irgendwo hin
was die ukraine nokia ausradieren halte
ich auch für eine nicht gangbare oder
eine nicht wählbare option von der
russischen seite abgesehen von den
internationalen folgen dass man dann
auch die neutralen verliert die russland
jetzt in der sanktionsfrage die stange
halten gibt es die lohnenden
militärischen ziele nicht für einen
nuklearen angriff erst einzigen lohnende
politische ziel für einen
atomaren schlag wäre kiew dann müsste
aber ausland auch erklären man müsste
putin vor seinen eigenen publikum fast
eigenen russisch-orthodoxen kirche
erklären warum man die stadt die
heiligtümer die kirchen die man ja als
die geburts oder geburtsort der
russisch-orthodoxen seele
bezeichnet jetzt in strahlenden schutt
verwandelt hat und das geht sich
politisch nicht aus sonst man kann mit
konventioneller feuerkraft das sieht man
dem mario pohl dieselben effekte
erzielen wie durch einen
atombombenabwurf aber weder mario pohl
jetzt noch noch jetzt serviert und jetzt
als total zerstörte staaten bringen
jetzt die wende im krieg oder werfen die
ukraine moralische aus dem krieg ein
atombombenabwurf würde denn den
widerstandswillen der ukraine
wahrscheinlich nur verhärten all das ist
sozusagen dieses nukleares schreckens
szenario ist alles leeres gefasel wenn
man es sich durch denkt wohin das führt
und was es russland bringt im vergleich
zu weißrussland kostet kommt man in
allen optionen immer auf den negativen
arzt es gibt diese nukleare kriegsgefahr
zurzeit nicht die ist psychologische
kriegsführung des kremls und ein
hirngespinst in unseren köpfen klare
worte von gustav kassel letzte frage
kommt von wanda calli wird russland
reagieren wenn schweden und finnland in
der nato sind das ist ja momentan auch
gegenstand der diskussion der prozess
läuft
ja
russland hat seemanöver in der ostsee
anberaumt russland fliegt auch mit
flugzeugen hin und wieder in den
schwedischen in den finnischen luftraum
es würde mich nicht überraschen wenn
russische u-boote auch in die
hoheitsgewässer schwedens und finnlands
eindringen würden und ähnliche
provokationen durchführen würden das
ende von gaslieferungen das ende von
stromlieferungen auch das sind
druckmittel die russland hat militärisch
kann es zurzeit gegen diesen nato
beitrag nicht vorgehen denn die
militärischen mittel die man im raum hat
die stehen jetzt in der ukraine die
sechste armee die gegenüber dem baltikum
finnland steht also auf raum sankt
petersburg die hat allein bei dem
angriff auf einen großen teil ihrer
gepanzerten fahrzeuge schon eingebüßt
und hat sich schwere organisieren müssen
die marineinfanterie aus kaliningrad war
in mario polen und jetzt in passender im
einsatz da sind ein großteil der
bataillone abgekämpft und die anderen
stehen jetzt in der ukraine im einsatz
es gibt zurzeit aus russischer sicht die
möglichkeit nicht gegen etwas schweden
oder gegen etwa finnland militärisch
vorzugehen
sagt der politik und militärexperte
gustav ressel ganz herzlichen dank für
das gespräch einen schönen abend nach
berlin vielen herzlichen dank